we are taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
we're going to go to our next caller
from the 503 area code caller what's
your name and where are you calling from
hi David uh this is Mitch from Portland
what's on your mind Mitch good I had a
question regarding uh Russia and your
views and contrast to Kyle from secular
talk okay I was wondering if you would
ever consider like having discussion
with Kyle or have an interview with him
because of your shared audience and your
shared opinions and views on so many
issues but with Russia it's vastly
different yeah I'm glad to talk to Kyle
anytime about anything I don't know what
his view is I mean I know anecdotally
people have emailed me and they said
David Kyle disagrees that Russia is an
issue and often times one-line summaries
from my audience about what other
commentators think are not as accurate
as some might might imagine but you know
I I'm glad to talk about that although I
think that there's probably other issues
that are important to both of us that
maybe we could make more headway on I
mean I think fundamentally well I guess
I shouldn't comment without knowing what
Kyle thinks but fundamentally there are
sort of undeniable facts and then from
that one can have a differing opinion
about what percentage of one's time
should be focused on Russia versus on
health care versus on whatever but I
have a hard time imagining that Kyle and
I would disagree on the facts although
although maybe you know more than I do
about this I don't know it I know that
on particular stories what's covered in
the David Pakman show is more highly as
Russia has more of an intact versions
I'm likely to talk it's highlighted that
Russia does not have an impact greatly
or not at all on a particular issue
sometimes Kyle says there is no no
connection whatsoever but he definitely
does
emphasize that talking about
single-payer health care is more
important like what you were suggesting
right there and that many other issues
are much more important Taco Bell
instead of Russia but he definitely does
believe that a lot of the Russia stories
are not relevant at all and that most of
them are untrue or a lot of them aren't
true
okay well that's that's a lot there I
mean I would be interested to hear more
about that I'm just not not exactly up
to speed on exactly what he thinks all
right thanks so much for the call Mitch
appreciate it always great to hear from
the west coast